to a blind person we're all the same so
i gave a lot of people chances and i
used to go on dates with anyone because
i just don't do that i'm like
don't don't don't do it this sounds so
awful but like so i did that i was like
what are you gonna do give them pity sex
like
i used to piss
i used to pity kiss people i give people
my phone number and be like i don't
really want to give you my phone but
maybe if you're showing me interest
and a guy so this is why i say
undervalued or underwhelmed yeah so that
was what i ended up in i used to be like
guys that i thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me loved me really valued me i
was like oh you're underwhelming i don't
think that you match drop and that's why
i've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because i'm like i don't
want to get hurt i don't i don't want to
hurt anyone but i don't get hurt and i
was like i'm actually you're also you're
being alone you're also competing for a
small percentage of guys too that you're
probably attracted you know that only
like